le ministre la paroi est à Monsieur
pierre Hérisson pour le groupe UMP
et aussi le Président c'est le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues monsieur s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre du Budget
je crains monsieur le ministre que nous
n'ayons pas fini de découvrir les
mauvaises surprises je cite du mauvais
budget du ministère de l'écologie pour
reprendre les mots de la première
sacrifiée du budget 2014 en voilà une
surprise votre gouvernement a prévu de
réduire de 10% le budget des agences de
l'eau en 2014 en le faisant vous feriez
une double faute ce n'est pas un
établissement public de l'État que vous
serrez de 10%, c'est un secteur
économique que vous déprimez le secteur
de l'eau potable et de l'assainissement
les agences de l'eau sont financés par
la facture de l'eau et le rendre en
subvention ou collectivités locales le
multiplicateur macroéconomique est connu
de 110 millions d'euros de subventions
c'est 600 millions de travaux qu'il faut
supprimer des programmes c'est surtout
plus de 1000 emplois 1000 emplois que
vous rayez des emplois très locaux non
délocalisables la France ne peut
s'offrir sur la
la vérité c'est que ce sont une fois de
plus les collectivités qui payeront vous
aviez promis de répartir l'effort de
réduction de 1 milliard 500 millions
d'euros à part égale entre l'État et les
collectivités alors pourquoi faire
porter 40% de l'effort prévu par tous
les opérateurs de l'État sur les seules
agences de l'eau elle finance les
collectivités et vous renvoyer ainsi la
charge de l'État sur les collectivités
nous vous demandons de revoir et ce
n'est pas demandé la lune c'est la ma
question votre répartition de l'effort
de redressement des comptes sur une base
plus juste le gouvernement a validé il y
a moins d'un an les dixièmes programmes
des agences de l'eau à hauteur de 13
milliards 300 millions en s'engageant
sur 6 ans il crée aujourd'hui une
instabilité brouillonne qui risque de se
reproduire sur les budgets suivants nous
vous invitons donc comme le prévoit la
directive européenne à rendre l'argent
de l'eau à l'eau nous sommes décidément
bien loin de la campagne présidentielle
et de la promesse du candidat Hollande
faire de la France le pays de
l'excellence environnementale l'eau est
notre premier bien commun je vous le
rappelle merci Monsieur Frédéric
humilier
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur les défis liés à l'eau nous en
évoquions les enjeux lors d'une
précédente question sont considérables
et recouvrent des enjeux multiples
notamment la gestion quantitative nos
concitoyens doivent pouvoir bénéficier
la fois de nos de bonne qualité mais
aussi un prix raisonnable et une
protection de la ressource des milieux
aquatiques ce sont des garanties qui
doivent être apportées et c'est
garanties sont d'autant plus nécessaires
que le changement climatique ne va
qu'aggraver les tensions liées à l'usage
de l'eau la politique de l'eau qui vise
à protéger la ressource à aider dans les
arbitrages des usages se décline donc de
façon tout à fait spécifique depuis des
années à l'échelle nationale comme du
bassin puis du sous bassin
hydrographique
les agences de l'eau jouent un rôle
majeur dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
politiques elles doivent pour se faire
disposer des moyens nécessaires pour
répondre à ces défis de la gestion
intégrée des ressources en eau la
politique de l'Aube bénéficie donc d'une
ressource elle est affectée qui légitime
la contribution des usagers selon le
respect d'un principe qui est le
principe de pollueur-payeur le dixième
programme de l'Agence des agences de
l'eau qui prévoit un programme
d'investissement pour la période 2013
2018 ont été adoptées en automne 2012
elles vont permettre d'orienter l'action
des acteurs de l'eau dans un sens du
respect des obligations communautaires
de la France relatives à la mise en
oeuvre de la directive cadre sur l'eau
et également ce qui est à lourd des
filles vous le savez sur les territoires
la mise en de conformité des réseaux
d'assainissement le plafond des dépenses
des agences de l'eau sur la période
2013-2018 a été fixée à 13,3 milliards
et les et les comités de bassin ont
adopté leur programme d'intervention
cependant un prélèvement de 10% des
recettes prévisionnelles des agences et
prévu pour 2014 ce qui correspond à un
montant de 210 millions d'euros cette
contribution sur la politique et de la
politique de l'eau en 2014 s'inscrit
tout simplement dans le cadre de
l'effort collectif de monté aux
opérateurs de l'État et il est
nécessaire pour parvenir collectivement
atteindre ses objectifs de redressement
des finances publiques que nous
puissions parvenir à cette solidarité
Philippe Martin veillera à ce que puisse
décliner dans chacun des bassins en
respectant les équilibres des programmes
d'intervention cette rigueur nécessaire